jour de marché de noël pour cette école
de maurepas des maracas des bâtons de
pluie ou encore des sapins confectionnés
par les enfants de l'école maternelle
est vendu aux parents tout cela aura
nécessité plusieurs jours de préparation
[Musique]
après le chant de noël place aux
activités manuelles ce matin cet atelier
petit gâteau pour les élèves de la
grande section avec la directrice et de
quelques mamans les petites mains
s'activent
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu es en train de faire
des mélanges tu mélanges quoi êtes vous
préparé koala comment vous les avez
préparé ses gâteaux comment on fait des
gâteaux
ils ont quelle forme les gâteaux il
forme de bonhomme en pain devise de
tortues ou alors que sap bien préparé
des gâteaux
oui c'est lesquels tu es préféré c'est
qu'ici chocolat et après la confection
vient l'étape cruciale de la cuisson
[Musique]
sont sages appliquée oui il aime
beaucoup ça la cuisine tu as été sage
c'est vrai tu étais très sage louis
derrière ces ateliers un projet
pédagogique pour les enseignants il
s'agissait aussi de préparer un marché
de noël liées au thème de cette année la
musique on a créé donc la peinture du
collage du découpage
mais payet pour que ça brille avec ce
joli on est parti vraiment sur un gros
projet musique nous doit classer partie
sur paris pour voir un concert où ils
sont vraiment très impliqué dans le
projet donc créer leur propre instrument
ça a été vraiment facile de les
impliquer
c'est une classe très performante donc
on a réalisé vraiment des beaux objets
des élèves et des enseignants satisfait
du travail accompli
reste maintenant à savoir si le père
noël a bien eu droit de déguster ses
gâteaux au pied des sapins lors de sa
distribution de cadeaux
[Musique]